I'm going to try it, I won't return it No
oops For me nb Manami Tani Everything Gar Alas Rams says he
doesn't like the suicide note Do
n't be on the side of handing it over Hmm.  I
returned the request for squid shells.Even if I reject it, I
can't help but turn the whole development into an enemy.
What the
heck, even if I regained the power of the demon king, I would probably be
able to win, so I don't want to give it back.
Well, I'll take it
easy, but I'll
accept the odds in the middle.  I
know that I can't become one,
but I ca
n't stand it, and I know that
you, a human being in this world, will take care of me.
8 Aircraft carrier September I found out that you're
Kagushi.
Please, I really love Tei and Yusa-
san.  I'm coming to you, so
throw away Karl and Omaro, Leon,
aren't you a complete villain?